welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 17 and
we're gonna learn how you can be focused
like a billionaire enjoy
[Music]
shortly after i met bill gates bill's
dad asked each of us to write down on a
piece of paper one word that would best
describe
what it helped us the most bill and i
without any collaboration at all he's
wrote the word focus
well focus has always been a strong part
of my
personality if i get interested in
something i get really interested
if i get interested in new subject i
want to read about it i want to talk
about it and i want to meet people that
are involved in it
in my 20s and 30s i was fanatical about
software
you know i didn't believe in vacations
uh didn't believe in weekends uh you
know
i was focused on software uh day and
night you know i knew
everybody's license plate i knew when
they came into the parking lot when they
left
and i knew every line of code
[Music]
and it you know i enjoyed being a
fanatic
and you know i was really focused on
microsoft
doing great software and you know
learning from our mistakes and hiring
the best
the best people today people come to you
all the time for money
i assume everywhere you go people say by
the way i have this thing you should
invest in but i have a couple myself
i'll mention later no i'm not just
kidding
no a couple of things you should invest
in or things you should give money to so
how do you resist you have some person
who says no for you
or how do you do that let many people uh
many people say no
well once you picked what you care about
if somebody has something that can make
a difference in global health
we're super interested and you know we
have staff of 1500 people
and if it's to do with global health
some of those people will come out and
talk through with you whatever your
innovation is and how we can partner
with you on that
you know so that's clearly in our area
if it is something that can
substantially improve k-12 education
then we're
going to be very interested in it if
people are asking outside of those
things
then you know fortunately you can say no
because focus is
is key to philanthropy there's probably
stuff you can say
about some insight that you had early on
and you thought to yourself ahaha nobody
else knows this except
us but we have this we have this great
this great trick
do you remember any of them well peter
thiel was really focused on network
effects
and he had this model that i think is
right
for making decisions that as the
complexity of the company grows
every day you're going to be faced with
100 things that you could potentially go
do
and your job is to pick the one thing
that actually matters
because out of those hundred things it's
really only actually going to be one or
two things that actually matter
and that was pretty informative to me at
the time because
i had intuitively like i had a lot of
some self-direction intuitively but as
soon as i started getting all these
people around me
who all had reasonable perspectives on
things was very hard for me to balance
that and
um peter was always very useful for for
that um
he was good at saying here's the one
thing that matters like focus on the one
thing that matters well
partially that and partially just the
meta lesson of
figure out the one thing that matters
and do that but do you remember what the
one thing that mattered like
someone wasn't connecting everyone as
quickly as possible because i mean
network effects were a massively
important part of this
one of the the stories when you say
connecting everyone as quickly as
possible you don't mean specifically
getting more sign ups
you mean getting people to friend one
another faster yeah well how did you do
that
um well we built a lot of tools to
enable people to do what they
already wanted to where you can't like
push up hill on this stuff right it's
it's um we were solving a problem that
people had and we just needed to remove
as much friction as possible
what do you think the three keys to your
success are well i think a lot of it
goes back to those values right i mean
the values often come
from the founder the person running the
company so i think i
believe those things probably the most
strongly of people at the company
um yeah move fast be bold right um
focus on impact and i think um
you know i think long-term focus is is a
really important part of this
and we've had a lot of opportunities to
optimize for the shorter term whether
it's
in selling the company or doing
different products that would have
benefited us in the short term but not
optimized for the long-term impact
then um and i just think you know
opportunities like this don't come
around that often so when
you get one i feel like you almost have
a duty to see it through
and build it to be what it can be i've
always been
uh focused when i was in montessori
school
the montessori school teacher told my
mom
that i wouldn't switch tasks and
they they got me to switch tasks by
picking me up including my chair and
just moving me to the new task station
i've gotten a little better about that
over the years but
it's still task switching is still a
problem for me
there's your completely massive and
globally dominant commerce business
first party and third party
there is aws amazon web services which
came out of nowhere and is now massive
you're in the hardware business
including echo and kindle and and the
phone
grocery delivery payments tv shows
you're now making tv shows
advertising jeff how can you possibly do
all of that exhausting me how can you
possibly do all of that
and do it okay even okay let alone good
so i think one way to think about this
is what are you really focusing on
so um you know i'm focusing
on those things that i think make amazon
unusual
uh genuine customer obsession
so like every single thing you just
mentioned when
you know when our senior executives sit
down and review those
programs they're looking for customer
obsession i would definitely advise
a small stirrup company to be as narrow
and as focused
as is possible to be if you look at the
original amazon business plan
there was no hint of anything other than
books in it
and it was not on my radar i was
thinking i wanted to build an online
bookstore
that was it and um you know worked way
better than i thought it would and we
launched music and that worked better
than i thought it would and we launched
videos i think it's so long ago i can
really remember i think it was actually
vhs tapes is that possible
and um and that worked better than
we thought it would and then i sent
email to customers so i picked about a
thousand customers and i said
besides the things we sell today books
music and video what would you like to
see us sell
and the list came back incredibly long
tails almost like whatever was on their
mind at the moment it was like
i wish you sold windshield wipers for my
car and i was like
really windshield wipers that wasn't
done the business plan but
that's an interesting idea and so um
today we
basically if you're buying your
windshield wipers anywhere else you're
probably getting ripped off um
and um so um so
it's been uh you know kind of one foot
in front of the other
i think um we have always had it's been
from the very very beginning you can go
back and read our 1997 shareholder
letter
and the the core of the company is
customer obsession
as opposed to competitor obsession
and that works really well for us it's a
i think that the advantage of being
customer focused
is that customers are always
dissatisfied
they always want more and so they pull
you along if you're trying to serve them
they pull you along whereas if you're
competitor obsessed
if you're a leader if you're the leader
you know you can kind of look around and
you see everybody running behind you
maybe you slow down a little and
customers are always pulling you
so i think if you want to be pioneering
if you want to be inventive
if you want a culture that is
experimental
then you want to be customer obsessed
rather than competitor obsessed
if you don't want to give up everything
you will get nothing
a lot of business people they never
learn to focus
if your startup learn to be focused on
one thing
right because learn to be focused just
like there are nine rabbits on the
ground
if you want to catch the rabbit don't
change the rabbit
change yourself if you want to catch
this one get finally get nothing
so for nine rabbits don't change the
rabbit
change yourself to catch that rabbit
until you got it
i found myself at the beginning of this
pandemic
feeling several things first uh when
lockdown came
i was excited because whoa i thought it
was only going to be like
two weeks and i was treating it like
vacation
and i didn't have to fit into any pants
so i was eating
everything i was like counting the
points in my head but not really
tracking them
and then when i realized we're gonna be
longer i thought after i put on
the first seven pounds i said whoa
let's get ourselves refocused and back
on track i was feeling overwhelmed
well but i will tell you that for me
being the practice of of
being fully present has saved me and one
of the reasons i was feeling overwhelmed
and eating my way through the first two
weeks is because i had just come off of
that tour
and i saw many of i see some faces that
i saw on the tour hey lisa shaw
i see you there um i um
uh and and i realized you know as more
and more information was coming forward
that wow i after every show y'all
shook had 400 500 people
waiting in line to take pictures and
shaking hands so i shook hands
i hugged people people kissed me i
kissed them we cried we danced we did
everything and then i thought 14
for the first 14 days after the tour
finished
every day i was waiting to like know
whether or not
i was going to be a victim of covet 19.
i am in the at risk risk category i am
66
never before have i been reminded of
that number because at first when
the news started coming out about uh it
affecting elderly people i was like oh
so sad the elderly people then i
realized they were talking about people
over 60 oh they're talking about me
oh i didn't realize i was elderly
okay thank you so much and as i've
shared with so many of you i had
pneumonia last year so
i'm really in that category of at risk
so i was worried and
if you're watching the news every day as
i know we all have been
needed it for information i have now
stopped and limited that for myself if
you're watching the news every day
you can get overwhelmed with the stories
and i was reading
every terrible horrible story of what it
does to your body and how it shuts down
your lungs and then it makes your heart
race and then your kidneys fail and
all of that okay do i have a witness
over there i see you linda and so i had
to stop i had to stop doing that
i had to stop doing that and every time
i would i would get overwhelmed i would
do this i would just literally
go to my breath and remind myself that
breath
is the presence of life it reminds you
that the breath
is literally the source of life for you
come back to focus and i would say in
this moment
i am well in this moment i'm okay
i am not in the hospital i am not on a
respirator i am not
that story in this moment i am breathing
i am well i'm okay coming back to the
moment coming back to the moment
reminding myself in this moment i am
well
this is widely regarded as one of the
most robotics driven auto assembly lines
on the planet elon part of the thing i
heard about the model 3 is that there's
too many robots that made it i agree
you do you think so too that maybe you
need more people in here working we do
in some cases the robots actually slowed
the production
yes they did we had this crazy complex
uh network of conveyor belts and it was
not working
so we got rid of that whole thing this
is cool elon
realizing it needed an overhaul musk
personally took over the model 3
production line at the beginning of
april
we're aiming for really extreme levels
of precision
more than any other vehicle in the world
he says he has resorted to pulling
all-nighters at the plant when things
get really intense i don't have time to
go home and shower and change so i just
sleep here
i want to see where is that oh yeah
i mean it's pretty boring overall
um it's actually cold in here too
yeah i like it cool so you have a you
like it cold i sleep on the couch over
there
so you're just laying here yeah the
couch yeah last time this year i
actually slept
literally on the floor because the couch
was too narrow yeah i was gonna say
and elon i have to say it's not even a
comfortable couch either no it's
terrible
this is not a good couch musk feels like
all the overtime is paying off
and now he says the model 3 line is back
on track
and we're able to un unlock some of the
critical things that are holding us back
um from reaching 2000 cars a week but
since then we've continued to do 2000
cars a week
do you think that this is sustainable
this pace
is sustainable yeah i think young people
you know in some ways
their their life is much easier than
you know sort of my life might have been
at that stage just you know for
i think all of us uh you know having
before
whatever if we're traveling to
switzerland it'd be a big stressful
thing how do you get in touch with
people before mobile phones arrange your
travel
figure out how to exchange your currency
you know
there are many things you know we can
whip our phones out and look up anything
and figure out how to get somewhere
there are a lot of affordances that are
such conveniences today that make it
easy
but there is also a global stage that
makes it hard
actually you know because
if uh when i was in school
and i was on the math team or whatever
it was just compared to other kids in
the school and i
did quite well against them you know and
i found myself yeah i'm good at that i'm
good at that uh
i think i find younger folks today are
their measures of themselves are always
especially you know the ambitious ones
are on this global stage they said like
well
you know i have to be you know number
one in the world at this or
that and i'm like you know that's a
really tall order
um and i think it can be discouraging in
a way
because if uh you know you know those
folks say well you know i'm number one
thousand on the world of this game which
which you know in my world would have
been an enormous achievement
because that means like you were
definitely the best in like your city
and your state and whatnot but
um but it's it's hard and
i think you know they get there's a
little bit of discouragement so
uh you know i would encourage young
folks to you know take
chances and pursue their dreams
and uh you know try to silence out
kind of the voices that say well
actually there are like a thousand
startups trying to do
whatever self-riding bicycles or
whatever it is they happen to be doing
and i think the key is to have fun in
your startup and not
from the beginning on to think of the
ipo which may bring you a billion
um that's keep and that was certainly
not your motivation to make it a success
yeah i mean i certainly had no dreams of
such economic
success and uh i think you're exactly
right
i think you should have uh fun and not
be
so weighed down by the weight of
expectations
um that i think sort of this global
network unfortunately
one of the downsides i think it creates
that weight the number of companies that
really matter every year
is probably between zero and five right
in terms of
like the industry changing so if you
look at an audience like this which is
what 1400 people
1700 people you say it's an average of
two founders per
company's presume everyone's doing it
you got 850
in the room right and so that's only the
people who are here let alone everything
else and so the question is is how do
you break through the noise is a really
really key thing whether it's financing
talent aggregation go to market etc
so how that then becomes a central
problem so one of them is
is to say well do something very
contrarian do something that is kind of
like
not like where people say well you know
it's it's
it's airbnb but for dogs right you know
or that kind of thing
is not the kind of thing to do generally
right and it's very rare that those ever
become the big companies yes extremely
rare
um the second thing would be is to look
where
really look where and this is one of the
reasons why both you and i are fans of
peter's question of you know what do you
believe that other people don't but look
where
other people really aren't right like uh
whether it's
you know hard science or if it was two
and a half years ago bitcoin
you know et cetera you know those sorts
of things were like oh actually
something could be really big here
because by the way
if you end up being right you end up
having
access to the talent that's really uh
that's really focused on that you have a
ramp to actually get a whole bunch of
stuff and get a big head start
from other possible competitive efforts
and these sorts of things
i thought a monastery would just be all
prayer reflection meditation
and a meal a day or something but a huge
part of it is manual labor
because they have to keep the lights on
and the monastery that i went
to which was not it was not buddhist it
was russian orthodox
they were the largest breeders of german
shepherds in this country
and i remember the first day i was my
job the first day was to be a distractor
so they were training one of the dogs
and i had to like run in front of the
dog and
you know try to like get him off of his
game to simulate
traffic in the city or distractions and
the goal is to have the dog be able to
walk unblemished no matter what you
throw at him and i was going crazy i was
running at him i was like you know doing
the far trick
all that stuff and um the dog
didn't waver it just walked from point a
to point b
and uh one of the monks that was
training the dog said to me it's no
different than life
you know it's like giving me all this
like you know wax on wax off
but he was saying you know you're going
to get distracted from your goals
and all these things arrows are going to
come at you all the time
but the same way this dog goes from
point a to point b even if there's a
pork chop there
whatever your goal is you got to get the
po you have to get there
even though people are going to say you
can't do it even though people are going
to throw
different opportunities you know you
know i'm sure your friends went out a
million times to happy hour when you
were to stay late
when you were starting your business i
mean i was in the same situation
those are the distractions that come at
you but to get to your goal you can't go
to happy hour every night
you have to return emails and you have
to check the manufacturer and you have
to
check the inventory and you have to make
sales calls how in your life
have you stayed the course how have you
stayed focused when
you had and maybe this goes to your why
you know what was it that
allowed you to keep going when your
friends were going out to happy hour
well i think like everybody i feel
overwhelmed a lot still
even though i'm older now and i've had
some success
and failure but i still have a lot of
arrows that come
at me all the time requests for my time
challenges at work challenges raising
kids
being in a marriage you know is not easy
i mean we have a great
marriage but it's not ease work sure um
and it's overwhelming
so for me i think part of it is always
having something
big on my calendar that i can look
forward to uh
every mo every other month
i try to put something on my calendar
for a weekend that i can really look
forward to so it helps me get through
the tough times
and i like to have one at least one
really big challenge a year
that kind of centers me and and keeps me
honest
keeps me honest and that's really
helpful
for me and then the other thing that i
do that really helps is
i have a journal and i just take
everything that's on my head
and i keep it in a master journal
doesn't mean i'm going to get to it
doesn't mean it goes away but it gets
out of my head
and it goes somewhere else to free up
space in my head
and then i'll just work it off or i'll
prioritize it from the master list but
just the
act of taking all the stuff that's in
your head
putting it on paper in one place where
it lives
is like really freeing and energizing
we set up three airlines um virgin
australia
virgin america and virgin atlantic and
um and they've all been very successful
and they've been successful um
i think well i mean most business is
successful because of the people but the
people
uh only excel
if you give them the tools to do a great
job and if they if they feel like sure
and um so i think um you know what was
critical in virgin atlantic was that all
every single little detail um was right
so we were you know we were the first
airline to
introduce seat back videos and five
years before british airways
and you know kids who travelled on on
virgin
uh would not let their their parents
travel on any other airline bushes
they wanted to they wanted seatback
videos and
um you know we had stand-up bars for
you know upper-class passengers and uh
i'm sure lots of romances started
at our at our upper class of cars
and we're not the kind of airline that
banged on lavatory doors either
they um so anyway we were we were
a fun bunny i'm gonna share with you
three things that i do every day to stay
focused number one
i need meaningful goals i was talking to
the to my friends
they're like how do you set realistic
goals i'm like don't set realistic goals
set
meaningful meaningful game changing okay
uh nothing's going to keep your focus if
it's not meaningful
right so like if if i tell you right now
hey
uh there's uh ten dollars
and your goal is ten dollars
uh that's not meaningful enough if it's
a hundred dollars
most people are like they're not gonna
do a whole bunch to go get a hundred
dollars but what if i made this 100
million
okay even though it's impossible i'll
promise you
i'll promise you if i sit down with
johnny and say johnny i'm gonna show you
how to get a hundred million dollars
illegally
in your lifetime if the payoff is big
enough
meaningful significant game-changing
this is why people give up on their
goals they give up on their goals
because they're not meaningful they're
not significant
there's no life-changing result a
hundred dollars
a thousand dollars even ten thousand
dollars
significantly does not significantly
change
a person's life enough even if you're
broke you say ten thousand dollars
would change my life forever oh yeah
until you do the math
and then you're like there's no money
here now when you start thinking
this big this is the whole premise of
the 10x rule the 10x rule is not just
about big think
the 10x rule is about necessary think
the think that is necessary in order for
you to even stay
in the game in the game focused on the
goal so number one the goal has to be
meaningful
significant literally life-changing
number two you got to have daily targets
every day i walk in with a target i have
a planner and basically what the planner
does is the planner starts off
two sheets of paper it's got it's got
it looks like this it's a notebook right
and this is
this is the right side we start on the
right side this is gulls
at the top and this is targets
okay first thing i'm going to do is i'm
going to write down these ridiculous
targets oh i'm going to get a i'm going
to get a helicopter
okay i'm gonna get a brand new
helicopter eight passenger i got it in
my head i got it mocked up it's black
it's got a 10x underneath it
dude it's got choppers i'm not doing
that this year ten billion dollars worth
of real estate all this
ridiculous stuff goes here 10 billion
worth of real estate
daily targets you need a daily target
what has to happen today
what what that i can measure today
uh in order to stay focused on my goals
tomorrow
next week and next month if i can't pull
today off
if i can't pull today off you know in in
uh
when you're recovering from drug
addiction it's one day at a time
handle today i used to go to a meeting
three times a day
three times a day every day seven
o'clock in the morning one at noon
one at eight o'clock people say luna
that's a lot of that's a lot of meetings
man 21 meetings in one week
but yeah you know what i don't wanna i
don't wanna fall off man
i gotta stay focused i'm weak the
devil's got me
the third thing you got to do and then
we'll open up the phones
i need to be held accountable have an
obligation to someone else i need to
publicly tell people this is what i'm up
to
i am not eating meat for seven days
it's not enough to say you're not going
to eat meat for seven days i need
somebody to bring me uh uh
the stuff that's not meat i don't even
know what it is no meat no dairy no eggs
okay so i need somebody to say hey this
is my obligation this is my commitment i
told peter peter make sure
i don't want any meat this week okay
everything all vegetables so
when i when every couple two or three
hours i need something vegetables i
don't even know where to get this stuff
i need to be i
have an obligation i need to be held
accountable i need a team
i need a team to say hey this is grant's
plan this week
i win you win every time
if i can stay focused long enough to
accomplish one goal
one goal then i can stay focused
to accomplish any goal hey hey hey hey
now more than any other time it's
essential you get your
your daily rituals in okay things are
going to get very
unpredictable for moments so right now
you got to get the things that you can
control
under your control i assure you
this situation with the virus and what's
going to happen more importantly with
the economy
is going to create stress on the systems
on families on finances
i've been saying for i don't know maybe
nine ten months now that we're already
in a contraction
that will be proven out now i'm not
trying to be right i'm just trying to
inform you
here to be successful you don't need to
be right or wrong you need to be
successful for you and your family
so what do you do what am i doing right
now discipline discipline
discipline get your rituals in daily
rituals
when am i waking up what's the first
thing i do once i wake up in my case i
write my goals down third thing i do
is i go to the gym and get my workout in
impossible
i miss this some days okay i can't
always get it done for whatever reason
then i'm going to have a target list of
things i want to accomplish during the
day
who do i need to see who do i need to
call who do i need to follow up on
this is going to become more and more
important
if you've been struggling in business
it's going to get tougher if it's been
easy for you it's going to get tougher
if it's been great for you it's going to
get tougher trust me
it's going to get tougher we've been 12
years into a massive expansion
the wealthy have gotten wealthier
the people that didn't change didn't
change
their finances didn't change while other
people got super rich
and that will continue on the wealthy
will get wealthier both start making
moves they'll expand while others
contract so don't get scared now
daily rituals set it up what are you
going to do
on your follow-up your follow-up
customers building
contact list building your your profile
of people that you can talk to
work with have relationships with you're
going to have to spend more energy and
resources now
to stay in touch with that base of
people that you want to
stay in touch with okay you want to
build and grow relationships with god
bless you guys be great stay safe
wash your hands wash your hands but but
be preventative man get healthy right
now load up on vitamin c
load up on vitamin d be positive
okay don't don't pass on all the rumors
and the gossip and the garbage and the
[ __ ]
take time to to be quiet within yourself
and and like say
get clear about where you're going these
are these are great times by the way
this
to invest in yourself and start really
clearing out
the garbage 2008 was great for me
changed my whole life okay 2020 is going
to be great for me and many others
clean up clean up your inventory clean
out your life get rid of the people in
your life that are
that have been negative that have been
maybe making you sick i want to talk to
you today about the tsa that's right my
friends at transportation
for the airlines look ever since my faa
problem looked like a problem to you
okay the tsa has been
nothing but nice to me and it reminds me
back
in may 21st 2009
my wife called me and there's a great
story here
and i just did an interview with msn
about it my wife calls me at 6 30 in the
morning houston time i was at the hyde
hotel at the intercontinental airport in
houston
and she says we're having a baby today
now we knew the baby was coming but i
thought it was going to be in june so i
planned this seminar because i'm the
delivery guy i'm the doula at my house i
don't know if you know this but
we do natural trial birth at my home i
don't want doctors
cutting on her drugging her and i don't
want her to be in a place where a bunch
of people are sick
broken hung over domestic
problem issues i don't want all that so
we had our baby at home so my wife calls
me
she says you need to come home i'm like
dude i got 257 people at a seminar
you need to come home she's laser
focused
you need to come home cause you made a
commitment to deliver this baby with me
and i'm like you're right i'll be home
what do i do i grab my bags i buy a
ticket online
i grab my bags i go to the tram in
houston trams shut down what do i do i
got 11 minutes to make an 8 30 a.m
flight
so i can be at home in time to deliver
my first baby girl
what do i do dude stay positive okay
no negativity allowed here i'm like stay
positive grant i just start hauling ass
pulling my bags
i go all the way across the
intercontinental airport i come up to
tsa
i start reaching in security security
line i'm busting through the security
line i'm like hey give me some help give
me some help i'm late i'm late help me
help me help me help me i'm begging
people for help right stay focused man i
know i can't make this flight
i know i can't i look oh where's my
driver's license where my passport
no driver's license no passport i've
lost both of them you know what you do
in that situation
you quit that's what most people do they
quit
cause quitters quit that's what they
know how to do what did i do
i say special attention i need some
special attention i got a special
situation those are two key words you
want to use in an airport whenever you
need help
special situation now you think oh
grant's going to drop the pregnancy card
they're having a baby today help me out
no dude don't do that save that you
don't blow
your whole wad at one time you've been
doing that your whole life
okay you say special situation he says
yeah what is it i said look i don't have
a driver's license don't have a passport
but check it out
grant cardone 10x rule i just wrote this
book is sick you need to get one
and by the way here's my photo right
here okay also on my phone is my
facebook account
and my twitter account check me out
that's who i am grant cardone you with
me
guy says okay come on through supervisor
i go straight to the line he says you're
never gonna make it
impossible you will never make this
flight you're down in like seven minutes
i said please have one of these
be positive bruh be positive okay
because if i give up now i can't make it
so i'm like
if i'm gonna fail i'm gonna fail at the
last moment this is longer than a
two-minute rant but why is it important
dude
don't stop obstacles problems challenges
keep moving forward i got on a plane
eight hours later delivered my first
baby girl i would never want to miss
that day and let me just tell you
something
grant you could have taken the next
flight i would have missed three hours
of my wife in labor
man i got a shot to watch my wife in
massive
pain for three hours and i got to be
there
supportive of her to help her to comfort
her
to take showers with her be in the
jacuzzi with her right
to to love my wife through those moments
where it's difficult
look the natural childbirth was the most
incredible thing i've done in my life
supporting my wife was the most
incredible thing i've done in my life as
well and making that flight
was incredible it was miraculous and it
was because of one thing
i kept taking action do the same thing i
love people man
i can't help myself people are like man
why are you on why are you always going
streaming live
i love people man
look what you pay attention to is what
you will get and the more tension you
give something the more you feed it the
stronger and more powerful that thing
grows
if you feed the beast your dreams have a
chance of becoming a reality
ignore them or deny them and not only
will those dreams never become a reality
but if you don't feed the beast you're
going to end up with all these weird
destructive
other negative obsessions that will rear
their heads and
pull you away from your purpose keep
your attention on where you're gonna be
next that
is the real present because you're
moving that fast
what are you gonna create next what are
you gonna do next who are you gonna call
next
what can you do that has never been done
before
feed the beast it's your future feeding
the beast will keep you
locked into your future and the
discovery
of your full potential
if you don't feed the beast you're going
to end up with all these weird
destructive
other negative obsessions that will rear
their heads
and pull you away from your purpose and
possibly destroy your life
at the very least look when you sit on
them on these things these beasts that i
call
and you suppress them or try to hold
them down i promise you
they will most surely contort into envy
fear regret and doubt i didn't scale the
way i should have because
too often i was doing either the same
thing over and over
and not getting bigger
like today when we find something that
works we're like okay how do we
connect that the 10x rule changed my
life
people talk about they talk about online
about the 10x rule
is a book that i wrote it was the third
book i wrote and
and people like that book is a game
changer that books one of the best
you know best books they've ever written
and it's on a it's on the most
top 10 most inspirational books in the
world but that that book was written for
me
i was trying to figure out at 50 years
old how do i scale
how do i actually go from in 2008 i
think i had
uh 300 apartments
well i had 160 apartments when i was
35. so
35 years old i had 160 apartments when i
was uh
50 years old i only had about 180 a boy
like i didn't have maybe 230 or
something it wasn't that much more
from uh 2008 till 2020 i went from 160
units or
i guess i had maybe 230 units at the
time i'm at 7
700. i have more bacon i have four times
more vacancies three times more
vacancies
than i owned 12 years ago
because i learned how to scale this 10x
thing was about how do i take double
down no don't just double down
how do i take something that's working
and don't do something new
take something that's working
i think about jeff bezos right now
because i'm like he he went from
hey i'm gonna uh i'm gonna go from
selling book
books on amazon to selling everything on
amazon
scale yeah so how do you do that
you you you study statistics and you
double down when you're winning i
ordered her a car
uh two months ago i told this guy i said
hey i want this car
he i called him yesterday i said dude
when's my car coming in he's like i
don't know yet i said dude this is
terrible
he's like grant they got to build the
car i said
such such like like
cavemen you know that oh it's going to
take some time right because if it takes
time it costs what
time is money and the truth is it's not
going to cost me money it's going to
cost them money because i'm going to
lose interest in the purchase at some
point say ah i don't need to do that
i'll just go buy a watch
same money you understand you understand
what i'm saying i lose interest i don't
need that product anyway how many have
done this before
wanted something for a moment took too
long
you disengaged okay you want to write
this down disengagement is losing
interest
i've lost interest i'm no longer
interested
can a customer get disengaged can an
employee get disengaged
can a manager get disengaged no no no
help me out here
can an employee get disengaged can you
get
disengaged sure man you got you just got
disengaged
we only been here 12 minutes these are
the people i'm worried about
people that work for me checking out at
six
don't put in the extra work got to
retell them everything
they're always pat me on the back you're
the greatest
why are you never here to the latest
then if i'm the greatest why you leave
at six
oh i gotta check out man okay because
they are checked out by the way anybody
that leaves at six
left at five how many of you suffer for
this syndrome i can do it myself
i can do it better myself hey you know
what ain't nobody does it better than me
that's what i believe i'm like i'm gonna
do this there's nobody i was talking to
ray this morning ray says he's a micro
manager i said ain't nothing wrong with
that bro
ain't nothing wrong with being a micro
manager but you got to get a team
everybody agree
i could be a freak on one thing i still
got to have these other 185 people do it
at 10 or 15 percent of what i would do
with that
i still get more done like that i got
185 staff in miami
at an average probably a minimum of 70
dollar base salary what's that number
seventy seventy grand times one eighty
five
it's gotta be 12 million bucks is that
right i'm so good at math
by the way math you need to learn how to
multiply
you'll see how close i am twelve million
nine hundred fifty thousand nah
[Applause]
that's what it is you guys gotta learn
how to multiply you spent too much time
adding and subtracting
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten plus two what is that
it don't matter it don't matter what it
is
a penny saved is it's a penny
it's a stupid penny
okay but a penny doubled every 30 days
a penny doubled every day for 30 days
a penny doubled every day for 30 days in
day 15 it's 84 bucks
at day 30 it's 5.4 million dollars now
i've got some special bonus clips that i
think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
you haven't said that this is the thing
this is what i have to accomplish today
this is the mission that i am on and
nothing is going to stop me
if you don't learn to focus on what's
important to you you'll never do
important things and live your life
reacting to what's important to other
people instead
so i recently started a new business
with one of my thought leadership
academy students jeremy he came to my
event last year
i was thinking about him on my tour this
year and said i want to start a business
with jeremy around youtube consulting
i get asked a lot hey evan can you check
out my channel hey evan can i work with
you hey evan can i hire you
for xyz looking at my channel giving me
ideas
mentoring guiding me and it's just not
the business that i want to be in but it
is a business
and so i thought jeremy jeremy's going
to come on board he's going to do it
now when i recruited him and called him
he was not a youtube expert
and i gave him the homework and said
listen if you want to do this business
together
it's got to be important to you i'm
halfway through my trip
on my tour i'm coming back in a month
and a half here's what i need you to
know by the end of the month and a half
and i gave him resources i gave him
videos i gave him insights and analytics
and said
you need to know all of this know all of
this
and then when i come back if you're
ready we'll start the business
and he did he focused he made it his
priority he knew nothing about this
and all of a sudden he became an expert
by every day all day long
grinding to learn by researching
everybody who is an expert at this
understanding their methodologies their
best practices looking through all my
videos my thumbnails my strategies all
the things that i've talked about in the
past
digesting it kind of like the matrix
when neo's in the matrix
and and he now he can learn kung fu and
now he learns how to
fly a helicopter all of that stuff
that's basically what he did
and when it came back in a month and a
half i put him to the test and said hey
let's do two free calls we'll take two
people from my community and say hey
free free call let's go and he blew me
away with how much he knew
because he focused on it he was a guy
who went from knowing almost zero
to now being an expert to be able to
really help
give value to people and now when we're
looking at new people coming in
i barely have to do anything because he
already knows what i'm gonna say
he already knows he's already done the
work he's done the research because he
spent that time
on focused effort and this is where i
think a lot of people feel like they're
never going to win because you may not
have had the expertise you don't have
the education
it doesn't take long to become an expert
it's just
focused work that you're passionate
about focused work
you could quickly become in a matter of
months an expert at something
if you just focus in on it and dedicate
your life to that thing
that you love you can easily pass people
who are experts at something who don't
love their thing
but because you're willing to take it on
you're willing to absorb think about
when you went to school
how much of the information you had in
your head but
you had to read over the page four times
so if you're at the same page four five
six times because you got lost you got
distracted
that's not focused work because you
don't love that thing
but when you love something how much
faster do you retain it
how much more enjoyable is the learning
process how much better
are you really quickly because you love
doing that thing
and so jeremy got really good really
quickly because he loved it because he
attacked it because he focused on
because he made it a priority
because he didn't say well i'll spend
half an hour a week trying this new
thing no that's not how you win
now where do we go from here we'll see
does jeremy want to be a one-man band
forever does he just want to be a
high-paid consultant does he want to
then bring on a team does he want to
experience he won't have products we'll
see we'll see how that
business evolves and flows but he got
here in a really short amount of time
because of that focused effort and
energy and that's what i want for you
i want you to take that big idea that
you have i want you to take the thing
that you have great ideas you're a
genius you're a genius
why are you not winning why are dummies
winning
from the same ideas as you from like a
half big version
of your idea they're off winning because
they focused on it that's the only
difference the thing missing
in your business's success story is a
lack of focus and a lack of momentum
i want to change that i'm going to give
you a three-step process on how to do it
step number one
what is the most important thing right
now like what is the most important goal
that you need to work on right now that
if you did
this thing that you worked on this thing
it would it would potentially have a big
impact on your business what is it you
have a million ideas
your list of ideas is not going to get
shorter by the way as you get older just
going to add more and more and more and
more to your list of potential ideas
it's amazing
but which one on that list which one
that if you just focused your time that
i said here's a gift of eight hours
go crush something what would you pick
what's the most important thing you
right now get clarity on it
number two is schedule for success
successful people have schedules that
support them
what is the schedule that you need to
have success is habits success is
looking at your calendar and saying if i
did this work
what's in my calendar if i did this for
the next week am i going to move closer
to my goals or
not am i building momentum or not
don't schedule according to other
people's goals schedule according to
your goals
and put everything in there how much
time you want to spend as a as a father
as a mother as a husband as a wife as a
son or as a daughter
as a friend how much time do you need
for yourself how much time do you need
to sleep put it in
create your calendar this is your life
build your ideal life
because if you don't schedule if you
don't have a sense of like if i did
these things this is what's gonna lead
to my happiness and my joy
you're never going to get it there's
always going to be demands for your time
there's always going to be something
that somebody wants to pull you in on
there's always going to be another
pressure from the outside
and you won't have the strength to say
no
because you don't know what you're doing
right it's easy for somebody to pull you
away
move you off your rock when you're not
stable on your rock
i want you to have a foundation you're
standing on a pillar
a rock that goes right to the core of
the earth that nobody's pushing me from
this rock
because i'm on a mission i'm going to
accomplish my goals this is what's
important to me to build the life that i
want for myself
my family my community schedule for
success
put into your calendar that one most
important goal that you have that you
laid out in
step number one that one most important
goal you have to have time for it
every week there has to be someone on
your calendar where you're spending time
on that
if your goal is i need to write a book a
book's not going to write itself
you're never going to magically have
free time to do it you have to block off
time in your calendar to make sure that
it happens
and step number three is create an
environment of excellence an environment
of excellence you want to create an
environment that lifts you up that gives
you motivation that boosts you it's
everything from your physical
environment look at
look at mine these people are here on
the wall for a reason
they may not mean anything to you right
you probably know
him and him and and most of you won't
know all the people
in between there that's okay that means
something to me they mean something to
me this is my environment of excellence
what's yours when you walk into your
office your bedroom your basement
wherever you're working your car
does it boost you does it make you come
alive
doing this setting this office up is a
one-time thing
and then every day i walk in and it's a
reminder it's a reminder to play bigger
it's a reminder to believe in myself
more it's a reminder to chase down
excellence as a reminder to not stay
comfortable build your own environment
of excellence
the problem isn't that you're not a
genius that you're not talented that you
don't have
wisdom and abilities and resourcefulness
and that you're not michael jordan
that's not the problem the problem is
you're not focused you're not doing the
things that you need to do
i just came back from video marketing
world in dallas
and i was being asked about where to
spend your time which social media sites
to spend time on and i think
this is a classic example of where
entrepreneurs fail
is you're trying to do everything and as
a result you suck
everywhere and feel burnt out tapped out
and not building momentum
if you get to the end of a week and you
feel like you worked
your face off but you look back what did
i get done
if that's how you're ending a week you
worked hard and you feel like what did i
get done
you're not focused you're switching
between tasks too much
instead of having all of these social
media sites at the same time pick one
and crush it
i quoted andrew carnegie at my event in
my speech
my favorite quote from him is put all
your eggs in one basket
and then watch that basket everybody's
saying diversify diversify diversify
have 18 different multiple streams of
income look at the people
who are who are one person show with 18
streams of income
they're making no money you're making 10
a month from this
and 25 a month from that and 18 cents
from this
you're not making money now as you build
and scale and grow and you have a team
like i do i've got 24 people on my team
okay great now it might be time to
diversify
but as a solo person you can't do
everything
yourself and you are a genius you have
michael jordan level talent at something
and that's what you need to find and
that's we need to spend as much time as
possible on
until you're making money you can invest
back into your business and continue to
grow
so let's look at social media great pick
one pick one
just pick one and crush it whether it's
twitter or instagram or youtube whatever
you think has the best combination of
what you're good at
you know if you like making videos
youtube's a great place to be if you
like writing
you can go on twitter or medium right
pick the one platform
and then spend your time focused on that
because if i look at
most of people's content you look at
your own content look at what you're
posting across these platforms
are you proud of it would you follow you
probably not for too many people so stop
wasting time posting mediocre garbage
and post quality in one spot and start
to win there
and then leverage it and then build a
team and then expand same thing with
products and services and business lines
you can't do a great job servicing your
customers investing back to
research and development coming up with
new white you can't you can't
not if you're doing 18 businesses at the
same time
i had a woman come out to my workshop
when i was doing a tour
and this was her issue she was in real
estate and she was in network marketing
and she was in
five different business lines she said
well i need to diversify diversify what
you don't have anything yet
you're diversifying yourself out of a
life
out of an income out of a business where
if you just had one
super strong pillar that then won
you'll win now the argument for
diversification is well if one thing
crumbles you got something else
great but here's what people are missing
if youtube crumbles
i'll take my skill set and go somewhere
else if my business
crumbles i'm still me i'll take my skill
set
and move somewhere else look at jake
paul and logan paul they were on vine
they crushed it on vine top people on
vine vine closes down
right almost overnight closes down great
they have a skill set they come to
youtube and blow up
and get millions of subscribers if
youtube goes away
for me my skill set is applicable to
wherever people are going to watch video
content next
if your business goes away the skills
that you've learned
will go somewhere else you haven't lost
you haven't forgotten how to do your
thing
diversification is only important when
you don't know what you're doing
that's why it's a great investment
strategy because you can't control the
company
if if google starts tanking because they
have some lawsuit
you have no control over that so yes you
need to diversify
right at the u.s economy tanks you
should have a diversified
portfolio because you can't control that
but when you can control it when it's
your business
i'm in the i'm in the line of andrew
carnegie who was the richest
human on the planet when he was alive
and he said put all your eggs in one
basket and then watch
that basket your chances of success go
up in direct proportion to your ability
to
one pick the right things to work on and
then
two focus on executing those things
it's so easy as an entrepreneur to get
distracted we love shiny objects right
we love
dreaming up new ideas and chasing these
different projects
but if you look at a typical
entrepreneur you'll see that
so many of their projects start and stop
and start and stop and you take
something
10 through or 50 through or sometimes
even like 80
through but unless you're willing to
take it to 100 you're not going to get
the results
you're not going to get the fruit of
your labor because you're just planting
a whole bunch of seeds
constantly but you're never taking care
of that seed you're never watering it
right if you want to grow a plant
you got to plant the seed you got to
care for the soil you got to add
nutrients you got to water it daily it's
got to have enough sunshine
you got to look after that seed where
most entrepreneurs they don't
they're starting to stop and starting to
stop and start stopping and you never
actually get to where you want to go
people talk about diversification you
need diversifying you need to diversify
and while that's really great as an
investment strategy if you don't know
what you're investing into it's good to
have a big portfolio of different things
so that if one thing doesn't do well
something else is doing well but it
really sucks as business advice
because if you're trying to do 10
different things at once they're all
going to be mediocre they're all going
to be
below average because you're going up
against people who are doing that full
time
and have their focus on it and so it's
much better as an entrepreneur
to one pick the things that you want to
focus on right and then
two actually focus on it do that work
andrew carnegie was once the richest
person in the world and he had a great
quote saying how he likes to put all of
his eggs in one basket
and then you watch that basket carefully
right it's only a major risk if you're
not
watching the basket if you if you take
your eye off the ball you start looking
elsewhere
and then something happens to your
industry right and so
being the expert being the best at what
you do
will always yield more results more
value more money to you
than being okay at 20 different things
be the best
at one thing focus and i know that's
tough because there's so many different
opportunities there's so many different
ideas that
we come across as an example when i got
the chance to work with lily
and i took her under my wing and now
she's working for me as we start to
build up her business as being a public
speaker
lilly takes up my wednesdays and
wednesday was supposed to be
write my third book day and the third
book is something i'm really passionate
about really excited about it's going to
be how to change your environment
how to create an environment for success
from your morning routines to your
habits to your rituals to your friends
to the physical environment
i'm really passionate about writing that
book and i need to do a lot of research
to be able to complete it but i can't do
lily and the book at the same time i had
that one day open per week because the
other days are full
at least for now and i had to decide
book or lily and i picked lily
and so the book is on the back burner i
haven't touched that in months
and i could try to do both but they
would both be mediocre
and i wanted to see lily have massive
success and maybe when i could build her
up to the point where
she's more free to do her own thing and
doesn't need as much of my time
i can go back and do the book i had a
guy write to me
talking about my facebook strategy and
said hey if you do facebook better if
you change the pictures that look like
this and if you
do more live streams and give me all
sorts of suggestions and
and they're great suggestions this is
the challenge like these are great ideas
but i can't focus on doing that and
doing what i'm currently doing
at the same time and so you have to
prioritize
focusing means saying no you're going to
have tons of opportunities come to you
tons of ideas
that flow through your head that could
all be fantastic ideas
but you cannot do all of them right now
so you need to prioritize pick the right
things to work on and then put your
blinders on
focus and just go out and execute you
need to be in execution mode
you got to get that thing done and it's
great to dream and it's great to have
the big vision and the big picture and
lots of opportunities
but until you start acting so you start
doing
none of the stuff is gonna happen focus
on service will
immediately reduce anxiety reduce your
stress
and reduce the lack of self-love that
you're feeling
okay so that's service great but how do
i serve whom do i serve well that comes
back to your why
your why is your purpose your purpose
comes from your pain
the people who you'll love helping for
the rest of your life
are the people who currently are who you
used to be
think about who you used to be think
about what you used to struggle with
the demons that you were fighting the
hole that you were in
you are much better now than who you
used to be think about your most painful
moment
not physical pain of breaking i broke my
neck in two spots that was my most
physical
pain but not that emotional pain when
did you feel the most worthless
when did you feel the most worthless as
a human being
when was that for you and then recognize
that there are millions of people right
now
who are struggling with the same thing
they feel worthless they feel the same
worthlessness that you felt they're
struggling with the exact same thing
exact same thing that yours that you
struggled with
right now they're in the depths of it
you've come out you're not where you
want to be
you still got a lot of growth left you
still want to improve you still want to
do
a lot more but you're way better off
compared to who you used to be
and sometimes it helps to just think
about who you were 10 years ago
five years ago or maybe you already know
the moment in your in your life that was
the worst for you
there are millions of people who are
suffering with that same thing right now
your path is to help them your path
is to show them hope your path is to
give them the strategies to get out
because a lot of them they're so low
they're so
negative they're so hopeless that they
won't listen
to an evan carmichael or marie forleo or
tony robbins
former you didn't want to listen to an
evan carmichael god that guy don't
listen to that guy motivational
self-help bs
he doesn't understand me but you know
what
they'll listen to you they'll listen to
you
because you are one of them because you
know exactly what they're dealing with
exactly what they're going through and
exactly how to get out of it
because you tried a million different
things a million different things how
many things did you try to get out of
the hole that you were in
how many things how many times did you
try how many times did you get up
and fail and get back up and fail and
try a new thing that was
supposed to be the answer and then
failed didn't work again
and almost give up and almost give up
and almost give up and then you finally
found something one thing
that maybe didn't even seem like a big
thing and it and it
worked like holy cow this is working i'm
getting momentum i i'm
starting to change and starting to see
results and now you're here
congratulations you made it
you are an impossibility right you being
here
is impossible to former you you 10 years
ago
look to where you are right now i was
like that's not possible i won't be
there
i can't do that it's an impossibility
but you did it and so that's your job is
to go back and show all the people who
currently are who you used to be
that it is possible that they can do it
that you're just like them
that you were them that you might have
struck struggled and suffered
struffled does that combination
struggled and suffered as struffled
you struffled worse than them
worse than them and yet and yet here you
are you made it
helping somebody who currently is who
you used to be
that's the game that's the juice that'll
fill you up for the rest of your life
if you want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there